I felt like for 20 years I had to be so
just heads down in tech. I almost had to
convince myself that those passions
didn't exist. Pretty much every founder
I ever worked with at YC would always be
like, "Dalton, when are you going to do
your own company again?" Perhaps my
biggest regret is if one day I look back
and I was like, "Oh, I didn't get to
explore all those things." I think I've
always lived by the philosophy that if I
just pushed myself really hard and I
tried to do really good work with
interesting people, yes, interesting
things would happen.
All right, this is Dalton Plus Michael
and today we're going to talk about life
changes. Uh, I don't know about you,
Dalton,
I've had a couple life changes. How
about How about you? Yeah, there's a lot
of a lot of new things. Different
environment here. Changes for the
viewers.
>> Yes. Yes. There's a microphone like in
our face which is awkward.
>> There's some differences. There's some
differences.
>> Yes. So, what are you up to nowadays?
>> Well, um I'm now a partner ameritus at
YC and I've started a new VC firm called
Standard Capital.
>> Big change.
>> Yeah, it's a big change. big big change
for me uh as well a partner ameritus and
so still a ton of office hours which is
kind of crazy but it's been amazing I've
kind of been prodded to try to help make
San Francisco better and it's been an
adventure that sounds really easy fixing
San Francisco Michael
>> well as a tech bro
let me tell you
>> you all the answers right it's just that
easy you're the guy
>> it it uh it it has been humbling to say
the least. It's been so much fun getting
to meet public servants and just learn
something completely new. I think
they're all a little surprised in the
beginning of the conversation when I
don't start with like tech broancers
like like I don't come with my like
recipe for like why aren't what you're
you suck. Have you thought about using
AI?
>> Have you thought about just doing these
things? Have you thought like oh like
there's public safety? you thought about
just deputizing all adult males and
drafting them into a police force? Like,
and so that's been really fun because I
think that people get a little disarm
when I'm like, I don't know anything.
Like, I like government.
I believe in government, but I really
don't know anything. And, you know,
maybe one to six% of the things I've
learned in software and tech might be
relevant,
>> and the rest is kind of new.
>> That's very humble of you. You're
probably blowing their They're like, are
they think you're tricking them? No, I
think what I've learned is tech bros
come in pretty hard, pretty fast, pretty
hot. So,
>> okay. So, I think within five minutes
they're like, "Oh, this is a different
conversation." And it's funny because I
think a lot of the times I'm asking a
version of, "Can I just see what's
happening?"
>> Like, "Can I just look Can I look over
someone's shoulder?" No, no, not not
even like I just like, "Can I see
someone doing something?" Yeah.
>> And just start asking myself the
question like would and could I do it
differently and like that's been that's
like a very different approach
apparently
anyways to move forward why did you
decide that this was the right time to
do something new?
>> Yeah I mean look for me um to start with
I did 25 batches and that's like a good
round number. Yes. Um, I also have a
newborn. So, my daughter was born really
recently, like at the end of February.
And so, you know, you we've been through
this, man. You go through a lot of life
reflection around that. Yes.
>> Um, also, honestly, man, you you leaving
kind of uh I can't say that didn't
affect my overall psychology. Certainly
more top of mind.
>> Yeah.
>> And and look, I'm really excited about
what I'm doing next. I love the work. I
love working with founders and I love
doing office hours and I, you know, I
actually love the craft. Yes. And I'm
kind of excited to be a founder again
myself. It always felt a little weird to
be like founders are great and all that
and well I'm I'm I'm not a found you
know I'm just an employee here. And so
look it's really freeing
>> to just be able to start a new company
from scratch. Like we've talked about it
so much on our YouTube channel.
>> Yes.
>> U literally I signed all the documents
and set up payroll and
>> nice
>> you know I did all the stuff that we've
been talking about and I'm really proud
of that. like it feels good to start
something again. That makes sense.
>> So, in terms of helping everyone else
out here, I think it'd be interesting to
talk about in general, how should people
make big life decisions?
>> Yeah, it was funny because I think that
there were a couple people that I spoke
to about this that kind of put me in the
right frame of mind. The first one was
my old co-founder, Justin. And, you
know, I was talking to I was like,
"Yeah, it's been 11 years at YC and this
and that." And you know, maybe I could
just do this job till I retire. And I
could kind of just hear the like the
naked judgment.
>> Like I could hear
>> what did it sound like? I don't know. It
just But like you know, you know someone
for so long and it was and he said
something got to me. He was like, "You
could literally write everything that
will happen between now and retirement
if you stay at YC." And like, is that
the life you want? Like, do you want a
life that's that predictable?
>> Especially because you're like
financially secure.
>> And I was like,
>> yeah. I mean, you you you do love chaos,
Michael. Let's be honest. Let's be real.
>> I like chaos.
>> You love chaos. You thrive on it.
>> Yes.
>> Um,
>> so he knew how to push your buttons.
>> He knew how to push my buttons. Um, the
second person was my wife, Sarah. So, I
was talking to Sarah casually about what
postretirement um is like. I weirdly
love chaos and planning, which is a
great, you know, anyways.
>> And she said something to me that really
got me. She's like, "You've spent your
entire adult life in San Francisco." I
was like, "Yes, I moved here at 23." Um,
and she said, "You know, you spent 10
years giving back to YC because YC
changed the trajectory of your life."
And I was like, "Yes." And then she
looked at me, she's like, "So, are you
going to do anything for San Francisco?"
And I was like,
>> she knows how to push your butt. These
people in your life, they know they know
where to push you, man. And it's it's
weird cuz like I've always thought to
myself, you know, it's easy when you're
in tech. It's like, yeah, I guess I I
live here, but my users are all over the
globe, right? you know, like you can
kind of tell yourself like, oh, aren't
you post local? But when you wake up and
you're like, this is where you spent
your entire adult life, you know, you're
maybe maybe there's an obligation there.
And then the last one was um Steve
Huffman from Reddit who kind of casually
said um at some point in the last year,
and it always stuck in my head, I fully
expect most of the capable people we
know will end up doing something in
public service before they fully retire.
And he just said it with such an
inevitability.
I mean, it's as inevitable as like you
would have a will or like you would like
like or like you you know like how could
you how could you um look at yourself?
>> That's that's no more fairfish than him
being the CEO of a public company. You
know what I'm saying? In the scheme of
in the scheme of plausible things.
>> Yes. Exactly.
>> That's definitely plausible.
>> And so it's funny cuz like those things
were rattling in my head. And I think
what I've noticed about making big life
decisions is like people say stuff to
you all the time, but when it sticks,
there's something there's something
deeper going on when like you can kind
of live quote them a couple weeks, a
couple months later.
>> Yeah.
>> How about you? Were there any
conversations that kind of helped shape
your thinking?
>> Yeah. I mean, I I have to admit pretty
much every founder I ever worked with at
YC would always be like, "Dalton,
>> when are you going to do your own
company again?" Like, I'm sure you got
this, too. This was like in the top five
questions I got as a YC partner. They
were always like, "Hey man, just between
you and me,
>> when are you going to start your own
company again?" I'd be like, "No, no,
no. This is a great, you know, I always
had my answer, but it was it's kind of
always top of mind when someone's a YC
partner is that we're all founders
>> and it's kind of hard to corral founders
in any one place for an extended period
of time.
>> It is tricky. It helps when they're
having kids or otherwise life
distracted."
>> Yeah, I think that. So, that was
certainly something that stuck in my
mind. And it's just the constant
questions about that. And you know, I've
been I had various answers that were
that were true. Yeah. Um and then look,
man, talking to my to my wife and my
family just about
>> having complete agency
>> over my calendar, agency over what I
spend time on, agency over all that
stuff is it's like pretty important.
>> Yeah. And if you again, if you think
about the advice that we've been giving
to people on YouTube all these years, we
always just tell people opt for the high
agency route.
>> Yeah. opt for doing your own thing.
Yeah. Even if it's hard, you're going to
like yourself more about it. Yes. Than
than than doing the comfortable thing,
you know? And so I think, yeah, talking
to my wife about a lot of this stuff in
terms of,
>> you know, our calendar and our home
life, this made a bunch of sense. And
look, I'm super excited about how well
AI is working for our portfolio
companies.
>> Yes.
>> And so, if you think about it, this is
my equivalent of starting my own startup
using AI. Sure.
>> So, I have founder market fit to be an
investor. It' be very hard for me to go
start a true pure play AI company.
>> Well, you got to be careful about that
founder term because you know people on
Twitter yell at VCs when they
>> It's true. Well, I think it's when
they're like not the founders of their
VC firm. They just say they're
operators. So, put it like that is true.
>> Paul Graham really is the founder of YC.
>> Does that make sense? Like he's Paul
Graham is a founder
>> by starting a founding investor.
>> Yeah. I So, I think that's completely
fair. But the founders of the VC firms,
I do think they deserve the title.
>> That's fair.
>> I think you know, Ben and Mark from
Andre, those were the founders of Andre.
>> Well, and there aren't that many. I've
been surprised at how few people it
seems like start funds to build
institutions.
>> Yeah, it it's hard
>> hard. I agree. And so that weighed
heavily on me and like, you know, the
there's there's this big innovator's
dilemma thing where if you're trying to
graft AI onto an existing business, it's
much harder than starting something for
from scratch. Yeah. So just across the
YC portfolio in general, we like to fund
from scratch disruptors to existing
industries that that are using AI to run
their thing versus trying to
>> buy a company and then put AI on it.
This came up so aggressively in the
mobile world where like you and I both
know so many people who are working on
mobile startups before iPhone and like
you would think they were in the best
position. You know it's like oh they're
all squared away like they were in
mobile iPhone happens. None of the YC
winners
had that profile. Yep. Like all of the
YC winners in mobile started after
mobile came out. And so I do think there
is something about if a new technology
hits having to start from scratch
otherwise you like are you really going
to embrace and and adopt the new
technology or is there always going to
be
>> it's the classic innovators moment you
have to like again we see this in our
current SAS portfolio. I see a lot of
people have a ton of revenue in SAS.
>> Yes.
>> And they know they're going to get
disrupted by AI but that means they have
to give up all that revenue.
>> Yes.
>> You you've done these office hours. I've
been doing a lot of these. know it's
hard to to cut off the thing that's been
working and got you this far. Yes. uh in
lie of doing something new. And so, you
know, that weighed heavily uh on my
mind. And honestly, like talking to
founders has been inspiring to me, too,
because there's like, you know, find
your own way to do it, but keep doing
the work, man. Like, keep doing your
wacky investing stuff. And
>> I I think it's been super cool like all
the notes that I got. I know you got
them, too, announcing that I was doing
this and leaving YC. Just the sheer
amount of
>> good vibes.
>> Yeah, that was kind of crazy. I think
that like uh as an aside, a maybe
weirdly unfortunate part of doing YC for
so long is that like you
touch so many people's lives, but for
you that's just the dayto-day.
>> Yeah.
>> And uh seeing all that response that
both of us got when we announced we were
leaving, I was like, "Oh crap." Like it
was just this like really big reminder
like, "Oh my god, like you're a main
character."
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> In thousands of people's lives.
>> Yeah. It was pretty cool. Like it's like
the what's the thing? Um the Mark Twain
story where he attended his own funeral.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> And like to hear what people say. Yes.
>> Uh it's pretty cool. And you would you
would never get that amount of
>> of good vibes in any other circumstance
except when there's a big life change.
And so it's one way to kind of take
stock of where you're at in life.
>> It's a feedback loop you only get access
to if you take a big leap.
>> Yeah. No, I totally agree. I think the
other thing for me and I think you know
different people are built differently.
I remember having a lot of passions
outside of tech and I remember when I
was trying to make this decision I felt
like for 20 years I had to be so just
heads down in tech. I almost had to
convince myself that those passions
didn't exist because it's like this is a
hard game and like when you're not
focused it's an impossible game. But one
of the weird things that kind of one of
the weird techniques that helped me um I
got kicked out of college and in order
to
kind of get the motivation to go back
and graduate from Yale I was like I need
to make a life plan. I think what I was
really responding to was that these
institutions in the moment like Yale
weren't motivating me. Like I thought
I'd be as motivated to graduate from
Yale as I was to get into it. And like
completely not the case. And so I was
kind of like, all right, I got to put
some other things out there where like
graduating is going to be prerequisite,
but like this thing isn't the actual
endgame. And so for me it was a simple
plan. And it was 20's money, 30s family,
40s government, retire and teach.
>> That was a plan that I made when I was
21 years old.
>> When you're 21.
>> When I was 21 years old, Dalton. And it
was funny. I I said this to somebody and
they were like, "You're crazy." Like
they were like, "It is crazy that you
would consider planning your whole
life." And I feel like people who know
me really well, they're like, "That's
pretty on brand." But for this person,
Michael, it's a little crazy to plan
your whole life. I'm not I'm not with
you on this one, man. I'm not I'm not
with you. Um, not for everyone, right?
Not for your mileage might vary, but
it's been 20 years
and things have awkwardly
followed that plan. And so, um, you
know, I just turned, uh, 42 and I was
kind of, I think subconsciously in the
back of my head, it was kind of like the
plan, like what about the plan? The
plan's been working. What about the
plan? And
>> I would have been more than happy to
change the plan if I felt like it needed
to be changed, right? Like, who cares,
right? It's not like I every thing was
really perfectly laid out. And by the
way, that's not that detailed of a plan,
right? diamonds,
one word per decade. But like having
that reminded me
about the other things that I really
liked, you know, rolling back into what
Justin said, like I now have the
opportunity of the privilege to be able
to explore these other things that I
like.
>> Yeah.
>> And perhaps my biggest regret is if one
day I look back and I was like, "Oh, I
didn't get to explore all those things."
And so for me like that really kind of
cinched it because it was like oh okay
like this is just the next phase of the
plan right this is just the ne and
what's really funny is going into each
of those phases I had no you know you
start a company with your co-founder has
a camera on his head broadcasting 24/7
right
>> you're not drawing a straight line of
money right and like you know family it
was kind of you know I was 30 I was
dating my wife but like we weren't
married we'd have kids right like d Um,
and so for me it was kind of like this
plan never works where you take a leap
and it's like a safe leap.
>> Yeah.
>> This plan always works where it's kind
of like you got to take a leap and then
you got to feel your way down. And so
that's what's been so fun over the past
3 to four months is like taking that
leap and then realizing like, oh I
really do like this other stuff.
>> Yeah,
>> I still love tech, but
>> does it have to be 97%.
[Laughter]
like it doesn't there are enough people
who can carry the ball on the tech side.
Um and so that's been that's been
incredible.
>> I think I've always lived by the
philosophy that if I just pushed myself
really hard and I tried to do really
good work with interesting people Yes.
>> interesting things would happen.
>> And that's kind of how I got okay
>> from just some guy in Texas
>> onto like this crazy life trajectory
I've been on.
>> That sounds like a life plan.
>> I get but you see what I'm saying? I was
like,
>> "Let me just do Yeah, it's totally life
philosophy, which is I should always be
almost like uncomfortable. Like I should
always be right at the limits of my
skill set. I should always be pushing
myself right to where I'm like
redlinining." And again, we've we've
done some crazy stuff together. You
understand what I'm talking about? Yes.
>> Like reinventing YC to run on Zoom.
>> Yes.
>> Co was fun.
>> It was It was right at the limits of our
of our skill set. Um
>> Yes. While having children,
>> you know, while having children. Um, you
know, I just I've always been my own
worst critic and I'd always been hard on
myself and I just wanted to feel like I
was pushing myself to the very limit.
And if I just kept doing this, that
would compound on enough time.
>> Yes.
>> To just have a really interesting life.
>> Okay.
>> And yeah, I've been kind of subscribing
to that theory and continue to do so. I
think for you maybe a question that I
would ask is what was something kind of
counterintuitive that people don't know
that founders
don't know about setting up a fund?
Something weird, something different.
Not like about like the strategy fund,
but just more just kind of like inside
baseball. At the end of the day, a lot
of the people at big companies or
successful franchises,
>> they know in their heart if they're
self-aware,
>> that people are nice to them and respect
them because they work somewhere that is
important and powerful
and you know there's two ways you can
deal with that. Either one, you believe
that you're special and so you're like,
"Oh, I'm a PM at Facebook. I'm a really
big dog. I'm so important." Like I
>> We love Facebook PMs. Some of the best
people on earth. But like you basically
>> I'm really good friends with the
Facebook. I'm sure you are.
>> You basically confuse the power of the
place you work with yourself.
>> And so you get
>> you dis you get entangled
>> where your identity and your work
identity are the same thing.
>> And you just get really
>> I don't know like you get confused about
what's what. The non-self-aware people
are just unaware of this and they're
>> you know they leave a they leave an
important job and they're just like
shocked.
Um, and then I think the self-aware
people are aware of this.
>> Yeah.
>> And this is why they stay in those jobs
forever is because they're like, "Hey,
if I leave, no one's going to be nice to
me anymore. I'm going to lose all the
juice that I had." And so I think this
is what keeps people, they won't admit
this in public. But I think a lot of
people are kept in various jobs. Yeah.
>> With the selfcorrect self-awareness that
the moment they leave,
>> no one will return their calls anymore.
People may be like, "Wow, these guys
have it all figured out. Like these guys
have it all locked in. Every day must be
stress free." No, this this is hard. Um,
just like I'm imagining trying to fix
city government's hard.
>> This is the hardest thing I've ever
done, man. Like I've done a lot of hard
stuff, but
>> to to start something from scratch at
this especially at the scale of what
we're trying to do.
>> Yeah.
>> This is objectively the hardest thing
I've ever done. If you're in that
mindset, I agree with you that like if
you only know how good you are when
you're kind of in that hard charging in
that most stressful moment, it's almost
like another reason to consider making a
big life change cuz it's like you only
really know your top speed and your top
capability in those moments, right?
>> And like ditto when people don't kind of
have to say yes to you,
>> right? You're kind of getting a real
grade, not like a not like a civilian
again.
>> It's like people in the government. All
these people retire from government jobs
and yeah,
>> you know, imagine they treat you
differently. Yeah.
>> Once you retire from a government job.
>> Yeah.
>> I would say for myself, so one, I don't
want to take on the mantle of fixing
government. That is that's at least more
than a three-month task. Um, I think the
only thing I'm excited about is trying
to help. But I think that what I can do,
it might be interesting, is just kind of
go over a little bit of what I've
learned.
>> Yeah. And this is kind of like a TLDDR
after I don't know 90 to 120 hours of
conversations with people in city
government, conversations with citizens
and thinking. So I would say the first
inning of knowledge.
First one I think I think what is most
obvious to me and what scares me might
not be obvious to other people is like
most people who work in government are
trying to do the right thing. Most
people are working in government are
capable people who are actively choosing
to take a lower salary to give back. So
that's like a big deal. So the second
thing that I've learned that's been very
surprising to me is like I expected more
smoky rooms. Like I expected more like
the people want this but we're going to
like be do this other
>> That's what people think about tech too.
>> Yeah.
>> Where they actually think that there's a
lot more coordination. Yeah,
>> there's not as much coordination as
people think.
>> There are many problems where when I
kind of got to the root of them, it was
our politicians and doing and our
government doing the things that we said
we wanted and then it turns out we
didn't know
>> it was a bad idea,
>> the right thing.
>> Like like it's so reminds me of like
listening to your users and your users
being like
>> they want something bad.
>> Yeah. like I want all the text on the
website to be black and the background
to be black and and it's hard. You can't
run AB tests in the same way. Like it's
this is a hard environment, but like I
was shocked how often it was like,
"Yeah, we did what what the voters told
us to do." And it was like, "Oh
okay." Um I think the other thing I
didn't realize is like in the same tone,
we as citizens drive the bureaucracy.
Like I think this story is not told the
right way. Like it's always told like
we're victims of government bureaucracy.
It's like we are actually driving the
government to create rules to make the
government less efficient.
>> Like every time there's like one bad
apple.
>> Yeah.
>> We are like put in all the new rules.
Like why? How could this happen? And
then like there's 50 new rules. And if a
company were run this way, it would
never work.
Big companies are run this way where
when something bad happens, put a lot of
rules,
>> scar tissue is to create rules to
prevent that bad thing from ever
happening.
>> But big companies can't do it as well as
government. Government can create rules
that you can go to jail if you
>> That's what's crazy is they they're
enforced by the police.
>> Yes. So that's I think that's kind of
rule.
>> All right. Fair point. Fair point.
>> But it's like but once again it's
triggered by us.
>> It's triggered by like somebody made a
mistake, honest or not, and us being
like how how could you let that happen?
like how could the government not play
errorfree ball like for hundred years
with all
>> and so that's like a a big one where I'm
just like if you think you're a victim
of bureaucracy like a city worker is the
largest victim
>> of the bureaucracy.
>> I think the other one that kind of and
this applies outside of government but
this really got me. We were talking
about this earlier like I took for
granted that software companies build
their own tools. That's just like a
muscle that they have that we've always
had. And I think that what I'm realizing
is how many organizations don't have
that muscle. It's basically if we're
using software, it means some vendors
building it for us. It's sad because
think about how many tiny tools that we
built at YC.
>> We're like, god forbid. I mean, most
people know about Bookface now, right?
God forbid we had to find a vendor who
would sell us
>> like YC alumni stuff.
>> We're like a vendor for the application.
>> Oh god.
like we would have
>> we wanted to change some text on the
application. We'd have to
>> call someone call our account manager.
>> It never would have worked. And I think
I just took for granted how many times
we were making our own tools.
>> And now I'm like looking at organization
that like it's very very very hard to
make their own tools. And it's like oh
that's bad. And and I understand why
right and but but it's it's it's like
it's harder. Um, I think the other one
that keeps on coming up, you think that
government has these powers and these
responsibilities and you kind of don't
want to make it a human operation. You
want to make it a machine. It's like,
well, the permitting process is bad.
This supervisor can write legislation to
improve it. These people need to vote
for it and then it's done. And when you
start talking to people, it's like
obviously it's a everything is humans.
>> Everything is humans. And so it's really
nice to kind of be the the Twitter tech
bro and like try to like solve all the
city's problems in like a tweet, you
know, and but just like the more I've
learned, the more it's just like, you
know, I had this thought the other day.
I was like, you know, it's easier trying
to advise a founder to build a
successful company. Like that's easier,
you know, with the amount of research
I've done. It's not like I'm there are
no conclusions. There's no
>> Oh, that's great. I thought you were I
was waiting for the conclusion. There's
no conclusions. I thought you were going
to fix something.
>> There's no solution. Like like this is
hard.
And by the way, like that's different
for me. Usually with this amount of
engagement in anyone's company, I would
be able to offer like advice. I am
nowhere close to like
>> so iPads isn't the solution. I'm just
kidding.
>> There's like all everyone needs. No. Um
to bring it back like I respect people
in public service even more. It's like
they're taking on the hardest problems.
>> Yeah.
>> They're not getting paid crazy amounts
of money.
>> We are making their lives harder as
citizens and then we on them and
then like they're subject to the wind
just like every other business, but we
pretend like we're in this hermetically
sealed environment the government
controls. I used to think startups was
one of the most stressful, hardest jobs
imaginable. And I'm like,
>> yeah, it sounds rough. this is
it's like yes like I almost sometimes my
conversations I feel like I'm just like
I have to express compassion. I'm like
this is
>> I respect you for doing this. So anyways
I think that's what's been kind of
humbling and fun and and like this is
where I live. So it's like if I want to
contribute to where I live
you got to learn this stuff. Most people
can have a me a renter mentality, but
some people have to have a bit more of
an owner mentality at some point. And I
feel like maybe I've been renting
>> Yeah.
>> too long, you know? So
>> that's very that's very noble of you. I
think a lot of people are just renters
for life, man.
>> Make some t-shirts.
Anyways, final advice for
people listening to this video
contemplating a big life decision. Maybe
it's starting a company, maybe it's
starting a family, maybe it's moving to
the Bay Area. Um, what do you think?
>> You know, here's the trick that I do
that I would actually recommend. I think
people are used to now writing prompts
for LLMs
>> and that you realize after you've
written prompts for a while that the
better the prompt, the more likely you
get a good answer. You still with me?
Right. like you have to spend time
>> very much so
>> and I think there's a superpower we can
all develop
>> of crafting the prompts for ourselves
and thinking about it that way when
we're making decisions.
>> Yes.
>> Which is like you know given these
constraints or given this and given that
and kind of like try to formulate your
thoughts into a very cohesive linear
way.
>> Yeah.
>> And then I think you tend to get pretty
good answers. And the prompt that I keep
giving myself is if I were doing office
hours with myself
>> what would I say? Because when I do
that,
>> somehow a whole different part of my
brain is activated
because we're, you know, we're so used
to giving advice about things. I'm
always like, well, what advice would I
give myself? And I've had a lot of, you
know, I'm not sure that would work for
everybody, but I've had a lot of luck
with that type of prompt. And in
general, I think thinking of your own
thoughts as prompts and trying to curate
them
>> is a pretty good hack, man.
>> I like that. I think if I try to extract
out the prompt perhaps I'm I I'm
subconsciously giving myself it would
probably be some version of you've been
incredibly lucky
when all said and done what's the story
that
can be told about like how you gave back
like in thanks for being that lucky I
don't think you can deserve to be lucky
but I think that like if you are lucky
you can kind of give the world thanks.
And so like what how do you maximize
that? I think is the is is interesting.
And I think YC gave me a great
opportunity to do that. But I think um
maybe government is one of the single
places that gives you more of an
opportunity to do that. All right. Well,
great chat. Welcome back. There going to
be more of these. Have a great day.
Thanks. Appreciate my collection.
[Music]